[Music]
when I was 19 I woke up one morning with
no feeling in the right half of my body
I just lost sensation in that part as if
a very thick layer of plastic was
covering my skin I pinched myself and I
scratched myself but I couldn't feel
anything that day I was preparing for my
first year finals in electrical
engineering but by the evening I
couldn't hold my pen after two weeks in
the hospital and endless examinations I
was diagnosed with multiple sclerosis I
was devastated I felt like my body was
betraying me and I was so terrified of
the uncertain future I walked around
weeks feeling so helpless but one
evening after crying the whole day I was
thinking about all the challenges that I
had overcome in my life and I was
reminded that in every situation I have
the freedom to choose it is true that I
have MS it is true that I cannot change
this fact but it is also true that I can
choose how I want to live my life and I
choose to live my life to the fullest as
if there is no MS I will take the daily
treatment but I will not give up on
myself I will study work hard travel go
out chase my dreams with no excuses
everything as before and even more
because that moment that I realized that
I have the freedom to choose changed my
life forever it turned the MS for my
biggest enemy to a gift because now I
value every moment I was born in Israel
to an Arab Bedouin family mad winds are
nomadic Arabs they traditionally lived
in tribes it's a very conservative
society
constitute 3% of the Israeli population
my father lived with two wives which is
a common practice in the Bedouin culture
but shortly after their marriage my
mother decided to flee the village she
did not want to raise her children in a
place where women are inferior and get
killed for reasons of what is called
honour honor killings horrified my
mother so she fled my father's house and
she moved in a hariya a Jewish town in
northern Israel there she raised me and
my eight siblings on her own we were the
only non Jewish family in town and I
found myself on the border between two
cultures the Jewish and Arab in school
my siblings and I suffered from racism
until one day the social worker decided
that we did not fit into the Jewish
society and decided to send us to a
boarding school in an Arab village at
the age of six I was separated from my
mother I spent three years in the
boarding school suffering from hunger
abuse and bullying this time from the
people of the village who were biased
against the kids from the boarding
school they considered us bad influence
they didn't want us to sit next to their
kids in class or even passed by their
home I literally had nothing in life
poor and wanted and misfit in both
societies and treated as inferior with
no father to protect and a mother who
was far away even when she sent us
birthday gifts they would be taken away
but one thing that I had one thing that
no one could take away from me with my
thoughts and hopes for a better future I
realized that I was born to this reality
but I could not change it but
could change my future and this hope is
what God kept me going and working to be
the first in my class even when your
choices are limited you can always
choose your thoughts and then this
happened at the age of 14 I was
discovered by a fashion photographer and
I became the first-ever Israeli Bedouin
fashion model landing large campaigns
with companies such as diesel and huge
amount of national exposure the phone in
our house didn't stop ringing some were
calling to encourage some were calling
to check if I'm still alive and some
were calling to say that soon I would
not be I was shunned by the Arab society
and my uncle threatened to cut off my
head if I did not stop bringing dishonor
to our family these were hard times for
me but I was again reminded of the
painful and brave choices my mother had
made for us when she fled the village
and like her I decided to live by my own
values not the values of my uncle not
the values of anyone else but by my own
values and with my mother by my side I
found the courage to push back and send
a message to all the Arab girls telling
them that we can pursue any path we
choose and cannot be stopped by the
chains of an over conservative society
and what I learned from this experience
is if you wish to live your life to the
fullest
you must choose your own values and live
your life accordingly never live by the
values of others when I was 18 I decided
to volunteer for the Israeli Defense
Forces so I applied for the student
soldier program in electrical
engineering and I was rejected I was
told that Arab
are not allowed to participate in
research and development in the military
and I should pick a lesser role this was
painful like hitting a wall but I wasn't
willing to let the IDF's tell me how I
could contribute to my country or what I
could or could not do so I pursued the
matter aggressively I sent letters to
the head of HR I called in favors and
get as many people involved as I could
all the commanders I reached out to told
me that this is a dead end there is
nothing you can do about it and you
better stop wasting your time but I
insisted and after a year-long struggle
I became the first Bedouin in the
Israeli history to enroll to research
and development students soldier program
I was over the moon I knew that I had
won and what I learned from this
experience is never let others tell you
what you can or cannot do never let them
limit or eliminate your choices you know
yourself best and you have the freedom
to choose your actions you have the
freedom to stretch beyond the boundaries
that other said for you
if I listen to anyone who told me you
can't I wouldn't be standing here in
front of you at Stanford when I was
thinking about the message that I wanted
to deliver in this talk I wasn't
thinking about you my Stanford and VA
community I was thinking about girls and
villages like the one I grew up in who
are constantly judged and chained to the
values of an over conservative society I
was thinking about kids from
disadvantaged backgrounds who have all
the powers working against them but
challenges are bound to be in life even
if you made it here to Stanford my
multiple sclerosis
it's not because of my humble beginnings
or because I'm a woman from a
conservative society it is a just life
when life brings challenges when you
feel that life is closing in on you and
you have no choices remember you have
your you always have your thoughts you
always have your values you always have
your actions you have the power to
choose
[Applause]
[Music]